they love you when they found out that
it was the new bachelorette is ready to
find a husband the ABC hits new leading
lady Hannah brown stop by The Ellen
DeGeneres Show on Monday and revealed
she's ready to say I do despite being
just 24 years old and I'm young but I
would not have gone on the show that I
really thought about what was I've been
to this and she dished on what she's
looking for in a husband oh man I got to
be good-looking you got to be they
lookin yeah but I just a good human good
heart kind strong but ultimately I want
I've ended this to know that they know
me I know every part of me and not just
some version of myself that I like
packaged together I was like do you like
this and I think I've done that in the
past right like the good and the bad and
I want that in return and while Brown is
happy with how things turned out after
Colton Underwood let her go from this
season of The Bachelor she admits she
had a hard time watching the episodes
back it's different for me to watch it
then just an average viewer because I
had a relationship with Colton and my
heart kind of broke my heart broke for
him because even though he broke my
heart - um he's a good human has a good
heart as for her own season Brown can't
wait to unleash her much-discussed alter
ego Hannah beast I think the reason I'm
here is because I was real I was myself
and I showed every part of myself before
she was named the next Bachelorette
she told ety she would make a great
Bachelorette I also was genuine about
how I felt and I truly did want the end
of it to be me and it wasn't but I
always go straight stay true to myself
and allows everybody to kind of see
every part of me the good and the bad
and I would love to have the opportunity
to continue on shedding that layer of
just trying to be whatever I think
people want me to be and just being
myself and I think I really believe in
and I do and be in love and find your
person so if it could be me that would
be great and I'm really sincere about I
think it'd be damn entertaining I can
guarantee that